jannis was machst du denn morgens immer
als erstes pinkeln zähneputzen und
kaffee um du ich gucke morgens immer als
erstes auf mein handy
heute wollen wir mal die leute hier auf
der straße in berlin fragen was sie
morgens als allererstes machen
los geht's
[Musik]
[Applaus]
was ist das erste ding ja was sie machen
nachdem sie aufgestanden sind ich recke
und strecke mich wie eine katze und
begrüße den tag wirklich das ist ja mein
freund macht mir frühstück hoffentlich
ja und dann richtig
das ist toll und danach duschen ohne
kaffee geht erstmal gar nichts das ist
die hauptsache und dann schaue ich
weiter
ich öffne das fenster lasst die frische
berliner luft hinein und gehe dann ins
watt also leider schaue ich auch mein
handy als allererstes und ich mag mir
das aber ein bisschen abgewöhnen und
habe jetzt er angefangen so ein bisschen
für mich zu sein
die sonne aus dem fenster raus zu
schauen den tag zurück anzufangen
das ist das was ich jetzt ab und zu
mache und auch mehr machen mag nicht auf
sie gucken ob das kind aufgewacht ist
und dann gehe ich duschen und dann
frühstücke ich mache mir meinen kaffee
und dann setze ich mich an meinen
arbeitsplatz und fangen an zu arbeiten
weil im moment aber nicht zu hause gegen
korona komplettes home office ich gehe
tatsächlich direkt als ich steh auf gehe
direkt unter die dusche und dann lege
ich mich tatsächlich noch mal ins bett
und gucke auf meinem handy rom
gute frage ist eigentlich
unterschiedlich also manchmal gehe ich
als clown manchmal gehe ich duschen
manchmal esse ich was manchmal machen
mir direkt ein café und manchmal mache
ich sogar direkt so ein bisschen sport
zum wachwerden
wie geht das jetzt einmal für fünf oder
sechs minuten besuche ich mir irgend so
ein workout auf youtube raus und macht
das dann eben direkt aber nur so ein
bisschen in den tag zu starten aber nur
mit deinem körper ohne irgendwelche
laufbänder oder genau eigentlich
hauptsächlich mit eigengewicht eigen
gewesen
und was ist dann die morgen zur routine
die morgen routine
erst bei gardine aufmachen nicht
reinlassen luft rein
der pipi machen und dann muss sie kaffee
aufsetzen
ich stehe ja ich stehe auf machen wir
ein café dreiminütiger ritzel setzte
sich ans fenster und rauchen und trinken
dabei und versuche das meine tag zu
starten
auch mit rauchen ja ok die morgen
routine sieht so aus dass ich mich also
ins bad begebe ich putze mir die zähne
ich duschen dann und dann schminke ich
mich vornehmlich schminke ich mir die
lippen
das ist ein sehr großer routine hin
tatsächlich ich putze die zähne ich
trinke ein warmes glas wasser ich mache
sport ich meditiere ich frühstücke dann
ist 9 uhr naja stehen sie schon um fünf
uhr 6 uhr gerade tatsächlich um in
italien starten genau und das nachdem
jetzt mache es fühlt sich sehr gut an
man hat sehr viel mehr vom tag oder es
ganz ist bereit für was kommt und hat
seine sachen für sich schon gehabt seine
zeit für sich schon genommen
ja und wie sieht deine morgen routine
aus ein glas wasser trinken dann gehe
ich mich waschen zähneputzen und dann
mache ich entweder frühsport je nachdem
wie viel zeit ich noch habe und dann
gehe ich zur arbeit oder wurden nicht
wenn man muss also handy ja zuerst den
griff zum handy und dann trinke ich ein
glas wasser und
ja mach die vorhänge auf dass die sonne
rein genau und dann fertig so langsam
wach und irgendwann wird der laptop dann
aufgeklappt und dann wird gearbeitet
[Musik]
übrigens wusstet ihr dass wir auch mit
uns ketten und zoomen könnt wir haben
nämlich eine easy german chat gruppe und
dort schreiben wir jeden tag über ganz
verschiedene themen und ihr könnt
mitglied werden und dann euer deutsch
jeden tag mit uns üben das geht hierbei
patchen wenn ihr das schätzt ihr
auswählt und dort gibt es auch einige
andere mitgliedschaften
schaut mal vorbei und werdet ein
mitglied von the german
[Musik]
und glaubst du dass es sachen gibt die
man vermeiden sollen nach dem aufstehen
damit man sich den tag nicht kaputt
machen also eigentlich sollte man nicht
direkt auf die neuesten nachrichten
gucken glaube ich mache ich aber
trotzdem dann wenn ich dann von duschen
ins bett wieder gehe und dann gucke ich
auf dem handy was sind die neuesten
nachrichten oder was sind die korona
zahlen
das mache ich auch gerne mal genau das
sollte man vielleicht erst später machen
am tag
ich vermeide in der letzten zeit
fernzusehen und nachrichten zu hören
zeitung zu lesen
ich bin genauso ich will von nichts mehr
wissen gibt es sachen die sie vermeiden
morgens zu machen weil sie sich den tag
nicht verderben wollen ja ich muss dich
telefonieren und ich stehe immer so auf
dass ich noch ein bisschen zeit habe und
nicht unter druck bin aber sonst liebe
ich es eigentlich in den tag zu gehen
wirklich ich bin ja rentner mittlerweile
ja ich glaube je nachdem an man muss
immer schauen dass man zum beispiel
direkt am aufstehen ist es schwierig so
auch sport technisch nur wenn man es da
wirklich übertreibt und der kreislauf
noch ziemlich unten ist dann ist es ein
bisschen gefährlich weil man schnell
schwindlig werden kann
deswegen muss man ein bisschen aufpassen
dass man nicht zu viel macht was ist
noch schlechter weg nach dem aufstehen
alkohol trinken für das ist natürlich
nicht so praktisch was ich wichtig finde
vor allem im home-office dass man sich
dass man nicht im pyjama bleibt also
sich anziehen der hose anziehen der
jeans anziehen und wirklich den tag
angehen und nicht irgendwie den morgen
total september sondern wirklich sich
auch vorbereiten auf den tag genau und
was ist die letzte sache die du machst
bevor du ins bett gehst
gute frage ich glaube im moment ist es
leider handy checken
das ist irgendwie so und vielleicht noch
lesen das mache ich ab und zu noch ne
auch auf dem handy
meistens wirklich inzwischen wieder
bücher hier vor zwei monaten wieder
angefangen bücher zu bestellen
vorher auch viel auf dem handy irgendwie
zeitung lesen oder sachbücher aber
inzwischen doch genau im moment lese ich
von von bill gates sind klima wo er ein
buch über klima geschrieben das ist ja
interessant das letzte ding ist die
zähne putzen und auf dem sofa einschlief
fernseh gucken oder mit freunden
telefonieren
ich lese ein buch also nicht ein ganzes
buch aber ich lese ein paar sachen
seiten in meinem buch ein echtes buch ja
das ist mir schon sehr wichtig dass das
letzte nicht das handy ist was ich
anschaue sondern etwas was den augen gut
tut er hat tatsächlich am handy wecker
stellen handy zum einschlafen
was ist das letzte was sie bevor sie ins
bett gehen noch machen ob ich das
verraten kann also wenn ich im bett
liege oder wenn ich ins bett ja
zähneputzen logo aber im bett liegen
habe ich nochmal revue im kopf und
bedanke mich können sie lächeln
das ist so schön das ist toll das ist
eine art meditative handlung das ist
sehr gut
podcast hören was hörst du film brücke
gemischtes hackfleisch mit und felix
loop rechts und warum ist es gut ich war
schon vorher felix lubricht fällen das
ist ja ein comedian und fand ihn immer
sehr lustig war auch mal auf einer show
und so und dann ich war nie ein podcast
mensch und irgendwie dachte ich auch den
höre ich mir jetzt mal an und dann bin
ich irgendwie dran hängen geblieben und
fand es gut
das mache ich dann ganz gerne mal damit
man nicht die ganze zeit noch vom handy
hängt und irgendwie bei instagram oder
bei social media sondern mal auch ein
bisschen andere sinne anspricht
ja wahrscheinlich hält mein buch aus der
hand ja tatsächlich noch gebundene wie
ich mag es kaum glauben
ja genau zu lesen ist es eigentlich
manchmal setzt mich einfach noch einmal
kommt und schaut ein bisschen raus
bisschen nachdenken was man so geschafft
hat was man gemacht hat und so pläne für
den nächsten tag ja oder lernen in der
prüfungsphase
ich studiere wirtschaftsmacht was ist
das letzte ding was sie machen bevor sie
ins bett fallen das letzte denken durfte
aufs kissen sprühen
wenn das spray zu empfehlen ja das
letzte denken ja aber erklären sie mir
weil vielleicht das ja das würde ich
wahrscheinlich auch gerne machen ernst
ist es gibt mittlerweile ist ein sehr
entspannter dürfte das habe ich auch von
halben jahr angefangen gibt sehr gutes
preis auch im drogeriemarkt dm oder
ähnliches die dann wenn die kisten spray
und das riecht sehr angenehm und das ist
ein schönes schlaf ritual bevor man dann
sich hinlegt auf das kopfkissen
das ist wirklich angenehm jetzt seid ihr
dran schreibt uns doch mal in die
kommentare was macht ihr morgen ist als
erstes und was macht ihr abends als
letztes das ist nämlich auch eine gute
übung für euch zum deutsch lernen und
wenn ihr lust habt noch mehr zu lernen
mit den materialien von diesem video
dann werdet ein mitglied von easy german
und bekommt auch unser transkript und
interaktive übungen für diese und alle
anderen episoden jawohl ja nich was
machst du jetzt
wir arbeiten weiter ach so ok alles klar
tschüss und bis bald
[Musik]